GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY WELCOME
TO LOOKS LIKE PROBABLY OUR LAST
MEAN OF THE PURGE COMMITTEE.
ISSORT OF WELL WE HAVE ONE ITEM
ON THE AGENDA WHICH IS.
AB TWENTY SIX NINETY SIX MINE SO
BEFOREHAND OVERNIGHT --
TO THANK ALL THE MEMBERS IT'S
BEEN A VERY PRODUCTIVE YEARS YOU
FOR ALL YOUR HELP AND SUPPORT.
AS WERE WINDING DOWN FOR THE
YEAR AND JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR BEING PART OF THE
COMMITTEE WITH ME IN.
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA.
SORT THAT ALTERNATE OVER.
TO WHO WOULD LIKE TO TAKE.
BREAUX WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO TAKE OVER WHILE I RESENT.
I ACT LIKE.
CAREFUL GIVEN REPUBLICANS HAVE
CHARGED -- A
THANK YOU WHILE WE'RE GOING --
TO CONVENE THE HEARING THIS
MORNING --
WE'RE GONNA STAB SCORE
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
TO COOLEY [inaudible]
THERE O'DONNELL [inaudible]
YOU'RE.
WELL THIS MORNING WE HAVE ONE
ITEM AB TWENTY SIX NINETY SIX BY
THE CHAIRMAN'S RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
AS CHAIR.
SURE MEMBERS ON HERE
[inaudible] NINETY THREE THIS
BILL SIMPLY CLARIFIES EXISTING
LAW REGARDING [inaudible]
OR VIOLATIONS.
THE NINE HUNDRED SIXTY HOURS
PURPOSE FOR YOUR LIMIT FOR OUT
LAST APPOINTMENTS.
A SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS HAVE
PROPOSITION WITH ME TODAY AS
CHRISTY PHONE FROM FIREFIGHTERS
PROVIDE.
TESTIMONY ANSWER ANY QUESTION.
MOVE YOUR CHAIRMAN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE --
AT A CHRISTIE'S DEL MOMBI OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS POLICE TO BE
SPONSORS THIS MEASURE WAS
SPONSORED MEASURE LAST YEAR THAT
MISTER RODRIGUEZ CARRIED FOR US
THAT ESTABLISHES POLICY THAT.
A IF EMPLOYER USES THEM.
AMP APPOINTED EMPLOYEE IN A
TEMPORARILY UPGRADED POSITION
THAT THEY LIMIT THE TIME THEY
SIT IN THAT POSITION BECAUSE
THAT.
AMOUNT OF DIFFERENTIAL THE GETS
PAID TO THE MEMBER.
A IS NOT PENSIONABLE AND SO WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT EIGHT THERE
WOULD BE OF IMPROPER INCENTIVE
ON EMPLOYERS IF THEY WOULD JUST
KEEP USE TEMPORARY UPGRADED
PEOPLE RATHER THAN PROMOTING.
OF FOLKS INTO THOSE SPOTS AS
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO THE PENALTY
IN LAST YEAR'S BILL.
TURNED OUT TO BE DE MINIMUS THE
WAY WE WORDED IT AND HAVE NO
IMPACT OR NO DETERRENCE OF THIS
JUST MAKES THE PENALTY TIED.
TO THE CONTRIBUTIONS THEY WOULD
MAKE IF I ACTUALLY WAS.
PROMOTED INTO THAT POSITION
RATHER THAN JUST TEMPORARILY
ACTING IN THAT POSITION.
WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DISH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK.
OF COURSE OF NEW PROMISE THIS IS
REALLY.
OUT OF CLASS APPOINTMENTS ONLY
DOESN'T APPLY IT.
YEAH I'M QUESTION FOR YOU WITH
THE FIRES --
ALUMNI SIXTIES YOU USE WITHIN
THE FIRES.
THE EFFORT I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT
THEY'RE GOING PASS THEIR HOURS
BECAUSE WE'VE OBVIOUSLY THE THE
VERY THE FIRES IN DURATION.
SO.
IS THERE AN EXEMPTION FOR THAT
EITHER.
NO HOW RECORDING THAT HE HAD NOT
CURRENTLY THEY EMPLOYER WOULD
JUST BE SUBJECT TO THE PENALTIES
OR THE EMPLOYER COULD ALWAYS
HAVE THE OPTION TO HAVE ANOTHER.
OF EMPLOYEE ON THEIR TEAM ACT IN
THAT ACTING ROLE IF THE CAPTAIN
OR ACT ACTING ENGINEER WHOEVER
IT IS HAS REACHED A CAP WOULDN'T
WANT THE MOST EXPERIENCED PERSON
LEADING THAT HUMAN BEING IN
CHARGE FOR SOMEBODY ELSE
CERTAINLY.
SO I MEAN IS THERE THOUGHT TO DO
EXEMPTION ON THAT IN A LOT OF
YOU KNOW AMER'S INCIDENTS LIKE
THIS.
I THINK THAT SOUNDS LIKE A GREAT
BILL FOR NEXT YEAR.
MISTER CHAIR WILL STILL.
BUT NOT.
PLEASE RESPECT WE WORK ON IT
TOGETHER HOW TO HUNT TOGETHER
YEAH I I'VE BEEN TOLD.
I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT I'VE HEARD
THAT --
OFFICER.
YOU BRING THAT HOURS AND AND
ALSO SOME NEW FOLKS THERE
LIMITED.
YOU NO NOT OF FULL TIME FOLKS
YES I THINK THAT WORRIES THEM
THE THE EXEMPTION EXISTS THEY
COULD CONTINUE TO SERVE IN THAT
POSITION BUT I DON'T BELIEVE IT
ABSOLVES THEM OF THE PENALTY SO.
OKAY TO PUT.
IT'S TAKING THIS DO THINK I
THINK ADDITIONAL QUIETNESS
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE THERE'S A MOTION A
SECOND AS CHAIR LIKE CLOSE
RESPECT REAUTHORIZE.
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RODRIGUEZ AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE
ALLEN [inaudible]
THROW NOVEL [inaudible]
CERVANTES.
THURMOND HAS AYE [inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I O'DONNELL [inaudible]
NOT.
THE THE BILL'S OUT FIVE OF AND
THAT ADJOURNS ARE READ HEARINGS
.
ONE BUT THIS GUY